- Cool. Cool.
- [Interviewer] Alright.
Alright. So Lima, you're back.
- [Lima] Yes, I am.
- [Interviewer] Welcome back.
- [Lima] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] So last
time you were here,
you spoke about how we're
going to do a, a scholarship,
is that you're calling it?
- Yes. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] For somebody
that has appeared on my channel.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And we
talked long and hard
about who it could be,
and there's lots of people
that are good of candidates.
- And I also asked for
comments from your viewers
of who they wanted.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Right. Because the funding
is coming from the viewers,
and we want to listen to them.
And we had an overwhelming
response for one special person,
and that was-
- [Interviewer] Yeah. And I,
and I also told you, like,
it depends on how big
a challenge you want.
And there's some people
that are, that are good for,
that, that would be perfect for this.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But they
would probably be easier.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Easier to deal with.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And who,
I go, who's the hardest?
- Amanda is the most difficult case, and-
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So, so you chose Amanda?
- [Lima] Yes. I chose Amanda.
- [Interviewer] Which I
think is very brave of you.
- [Lima] Thank you.
And I chose Amanda with you, specifically,
because you and I both discussed this,
and not only does Amanda have a lot
of people praying for her
and a lot of people that really
want to see her get better,
but Amanda is the poster
child of an impossible case.
So when people look at Amanda,
I think it's really easy
to think the word hopeless.
And when I look at Amanda,
I see someone that's trapped and lost.
And I think that if we can
use Amanda as a template for
what care should be and that
we can save Amanda's life,
then everyone can, can
see Amanda as you know,
a template for hope.
Though, you know,
so there is, I don't believe
in an impossible case,
but I don't think that
there's a better candidate
than Amanda.
And so we plan to document
how we're helping Amanda
because one of the most
challenging things about her
is that she does not
want to go to treatment.
She doesn't want help.
And there's a, it's when
it comes to addiction,
when it comes to mental illness,
a lot of times people
don't want to get better.
They don't want the help.
- [Interviewer] Not sometimes, 90, 99-
- 90% of the time.
- [Interviewer] 98% of
the time they don't.
They might say it here in an interview,
but you catch them after the interview,
and say, Hey, would you like
to do this, that or the other?
- Yeah. And then they might
even actually go into treatment.
- [Interviewer] For a day or two.
- And then they leave.
And it's really, really tough.
So we're going to be documenting exactly
how we're getting Amanda into treatment,
how we're putting her into these programs.
And the reason for that is
because I think that Amanda,
when she gets better,
that she's going to be an
inspiration for a lot of people.
Because when she, she can use her story
as a way to demonstrate for
others how to get better.
And what that's going to be
is it's going to give her
purpose in her life.
So I think that it couldn't be better.
And it's also, there's
a lot of things that
have taken me a while
to learn with my family.
So instead of everyone
having to fail and learn
and fail and learn,
then why not just share this information?
Just, you know, put it out there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Your
experience with your sisters,
I think, really kind of helps you deal
with people like Amanda.
- Yes, absolutely.
- [Interviewer] And then
something else has happened
with Amanda that kind of helped, right?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] She ended up in jail.
- Exactly. And that's
actually the best thing
that could've happened.
Do you want me to go into how
this happened?
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Please.
The truth is the truth.
- Okay. So I've had,
I have permission to state
this from the family.
And so basically Amanda had
attacked her father with a pipe,
and he reached out to Mark,
and he asked Mark what he should do,
and Mark suggested calling
the police on Amanda,
which was the best thing
he could've possibly done.
As a family member, it's
really hard to call 911,
and it feels like a
betrayal to that person.
But at the same time,
Amanda's in a safe place now
where she can't use drugs.
- [Interviewer] She's not using crack.
- She can't use crack.
She can't hurt herself, and
she's being fed and clothed.
And the reason that this is so significant
is the way that you get somebody
that doesn't want to
get help into treatment
is through something called
an LPS conservatorship.
And that's what we're using for Amanda.
What that entails is that,
it's a very difficult process,
because you don't want
to be dating someone,
and then they get mad at you,
and then all of a sudden
you're being forced to go to a,
you know, mental health facility.
So they make it challenging
because they want to make
sure it's not abused.
So essentially,
you have to prove two things,
and it's easier if it's a family member.
So Amanda's father is
working really, really hard
night and day to make this happen with me.
So you need to prove that the
person is gravely disabled.
Number one.
And that the second thing is
that they have a severe mental illness.
So Amanda has actually been
to seven treatment centers.
Nothing's worked for her.
She's relapsed every time.
She's kind of given up on treatment,
and you know, of course they're
all very short term stays.
And then the second factor.
So she's already been diagnosed.
Her current diagnosis is
schizophrenic and bipolar,
and we are going to review that diagnosis
with our team and a team of specialists,
see if there's any
other underlining issues
or if anything is a misdiagnosis.
The second factor that we have to prove,
and we've been working on doing this,
is she has to check off
one of three things,
but fortunately Amanda
checks off all three.
So it's shelter, food and clothing.
And so that's what grave,
gravely disabled means
is that the person cannot
provide shelter, food
or clothing for themselves.
So again, it only has to
be one of these three.
And so essentially by shelter,
the person doesn't have
a safe place to live.
By food, the person has lost a
significant amount of weight.
That could be a health risk.
And by clothing, it
could be that the person
will not change their clothes
for a long period of time,
so bacteria buildup
can also cause a health
risk to that person,
or that the person
takes off their clothing
at inappropriate times,
which could be a health
risk because of the weather.
If it's very cold, if it's very hot.
- [Interviewer] I can't
tell you how many times
I've seen Amanda walking down the street,
no shoes, no socks, no pants, just,
just a tank top.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And nothing else.
I'll buy her pants and shoes,
and then she'll just walk away.
- Yeah, so.
- [Interviewer] And just
leave them on the sidewalk.
- So basically checks
off every box, right?
And, and, and the only
way that you can get it,
an LPS conservatorship put through,
is if the person is in holding.
And so the person must be in holding
in either a jail or a
psychiatric hospital.
So let's say you walk in
on your family member,
and they're trying to hurt themselves.
You can call for a 51 50,
and then that person would
be put on a 72 hour hold
for a suicide watch.
And in that timeframe,
if you have the paperwork
already put together,
you have to act very
quickly, in only three days.
You can work with the,
with the patient's doctor.
And then of course, for the jail factor,
if someone is attacking
you or trying to hurt you,
you can call 911, and they
would be taken to a jail.
But at the same time, because
they have a mental illness,
they have certain medications
they're supposed to take,
there's a doctor that's involved.
And so when you have that
paperwork ready to go,
you would contact the person's defender,
and you would also contact
the doctor of, of the patient.
And so by working with
the healthcare provider,
having the document already
filled out and ready to go,
you can have that, that doctor,
it's only a one-page document
because it needs to be proven very simply.
But by having that page
filled out, ready to go,
if the doctor recommends that the,
the conservatorship goes through,
then you have one year of treatment
that you can actually
force on the patient.
And it's really important
for people to understand
that getting raped on
Skid Row, being homeless,
having a random person
inject heroin into your arm,
you know, having a threat of disease,
to anyone else that would be rock bottom
and that would be an
opportunity to completely
change your life and say, I
want to do something different.
This is not my life.
To someone that has been in severe trauma
and has become disabled by their traumas,
just completely crippled,
that, this isn't, this,
the ability for them
to do whatever they want,
which is essentially to kill themselves,
be self-destructive, is
not a rock bottom for them.
So they'll continue to
do it until they die.
And what is rock bottom is
that taking away that control.
So what we're working on is
having two options for Amanda.
One, the LPS conservatorship goes through.
She's going to have either
an actual treatment center,
where they're going to work with her.
They're going to provide care.
They're going to do the therapies,
and she's gonna, she's
gonna have that for a year.
If she leaves, if she walks out,
her only other option is
a psychiatric hospital.
And basically, they sedate you,
they give you medications,
and there's nothing to do there
except to sleep and watch
TV and walk in circles.
So you're either going to
be held in a psych ward,
or you're going to be, you know,
given the opportunity to go
to a beautiful treatment center,
where you have a team of
people working with you
to help you get better.
And if you choose to leave
again, back to the psych ward.
And it's just going to be a ping pong
between psych ward and treatment,
and psych ward and treatment.
- [Interviewer] Is there
a possibility of her,
of Amanda escaping and running back
to where she likes to be, on the street?
- You can't escape an inpatient facility.
So it's pretty much like
you're under lockdown,
and our residential treatment center
you can walk out of.
A lot of these facilities can be the ones
that we're going to be
sending to, Amanda to,
are gonna look like, you know,
beautiful homes that, it's not a clinical,
it doesn't look clinical at all.
It's just a beautiful home.
It feels like you're, you're
not in a hospital setting,
and they take you out on outings,
and they help you merge
into the real world,
while practicing these different skills.
So any facility that
Amanda's going to be going to
through our scholarship program
is going to be an Aura treatment center,
which means that it's a clinic
that is partnering up with us
to use our technology.
And so just a quick recap
of what that technology is,
is it's health detection.
So we do, we have the
computer, microphone,
we analyze voice, stress, cravings.
We use technology to really figure out
additional data streams to help the doctor
treat the patient.
And then there's also a mobile
app that does tele-health
and also the, you know, stress analysis,
mood analysis, voice
analysis, and all of that.
So it's just a mobile
version of the technology.
And so essentially with that,
Amanda's going to have door to door care.
So she's going to have
a year of treatment.
If she chooses to walk
out, because like I said,
residential treatment centers
are completely optional.
Nobody's being forced to go.
You can leave at anytime.
So they're not going to
restrain her and make her stay.
If she leaves, with the
LPS conservatorship,
we will have her escorted
back to a psychiatric hospital
where she'll be held
until she changes her mind
and wants to go to treatment.
And so that's basically her rock bottom
when she realizes I can't just go run wild
and free on the streets.
I have to change something,
or I'm going to keep
bouncing back and forth.
If something doesn't work in a year,
you can actually take
that LPS conservatorship
and have it renewed for a following year
showing that you have the support.
So if we're able to raise the funds
through the GoFundMe campaign
to pay for Amanda's treatment for a year,
then essentially we'll be able to cover
all of her medical expenses.
- [Interviewer] And, and
those are, those are signif-,
significant, right?
- Yes. So typically it
costs well over 300,000,
but the treatment centers that I work with
are willing to discount the rates.
And so we're also,
right now, we've had some
very generous donations from,
I think, about 20 supporters,
so I'm very grateful.
And we're using the funds that we have
to get Amanda health insurance.
She doesn't have that.
So health insurance will pay
for 30 days of treatment,
a treatment center.
So that's going to help us
off, offset some of the costs
and also, you know, detox
and hospitalizations
and medications on the health insurance
will also help there.
- [Interviewer] So we're
doing something against
Amanda's will,
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] but her
will is to kill herself.
- Exactly. Her will is
complete self-destruction,
and also she's not in
a proper state of mind
to make those decisions for herself
because she's unable to
take care of herself.
And everybody just wants
to see her get better.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, no, her
dad and I have been trying to
get the police to do a
51 50 on her forever,
but they explained that that's
just not going to happen,
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] especially
with COVID going on,
but even, even if COVID wasn't happening.
- No. Well, they're, they're
they're way over-packed.
So mental health is a massive
issue for the country,
but since COVID has hit, you know,
addiction is a disease of isolation
and so is depression.
So all of a sudden you're
having people mandated
to quarantine, and it's, you know,
suicide rates are spiking.
A lot of people are struggling with,
with what they're dealing with,
and the typical, the normal
standards of tele-health
just don't cut it
because when it comes to mental illness,
I can see you, and I can be fine,
and I can be smiling
and genuinely feel okay.
And then two hours later,
I just want to die.
Something happened,
I'm stuck on a thought,
and I just can't let go of it.
So, so with our, with our
telehealth application,
we're working on scaling that as well.
So we are working with our,
with our team to scale that
and, and bring it outside of
just the treatment centers
we work with so that it's accessible.
One of the things I do want to address is
I had quite a few comments.
So I am working on
responding to, like I said,
at least 10 comments a day.
'Cause everybody's feedback
is really important to me.
And one of the most reoccurring
comments that I saw was,
why do I charge so much for my technology?
And so essentially,
we don't, we at this moment
are giving the technology
to these facilities at no cost.
So we're giving it to them
for research purposes,
and we're documenting the cases.
And these facilities
are charging on average
$45,000 per month per patient.
So what we want to do
is we want to make our technology
available to everybody.
So we have a petition, two
petitions that I've started,
and what those two petitions are,
is we're going to use
Amanda as a case study,
and we're going to document
exactly how we're helping her
get treatment.
And with the funds that are
being raised from the viewers,
the ability to pay for, for an
entire year of care for her,
we're going to demonstrate that, you know,
we're able to reduce the relapse.
She's actually able to
get better and heal.
And in the longterm, it's,
it's going to save
insurance companies money
if they actually treat mental
illness like physical illness
and do long-term care for it.
Honestly, mental illness
is a physical problem
because there's something
wrong with your brain. Right?
And then the second,
the second thing that,
that we're doing with these petitions
is proposing a new administration policy.
And so what that looks like is
we want to start
mandating tools like Aura,
but it doesn't have to be Aura.
It can be anybody
'cause we welcome other
people getting involved
in this industry and
innovating and contributing.
So it would be tools.
So we want to,
we want to promote new
administration policies
in insurance and government
to mandate some sort of tools
to track patient progress
and also health detection.
So that we're not just relying
on, how are you feeling?
And so if we're able to get
a hundred thousand signatures
in 30 days on wethepeople.gov,
we will be able to,
we will be guaranteed a
response from the White House.
So that would be really amazing.
And then the second thing
is the change.org petition.
We're going to be taking
that to insurance companies
so that everybody that's watching
will also be able to benefit
from a program similar to
what we're doing for Amanda.
- [Interviewer] It's amazing.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I commend
you on your courage.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Because it'd
be so easy to pick somebody
who's an easier case.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- [Interviewer] But you
chose the most difficult one
you could find.
- Yes. Because I, like I said,
I don't believe in an impossible case.
And I think that anyone
that's looking at themselves
and thinking that they're hopeless,
when they watch Amanda get better,
they're going to, you know, sign up,
and they're gonna really
put the effort in.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yep. And then I do have
one last thing to add
is if anybody does want a template
of the LPS conservatorship
or detailed information
on how to put that document
through for their loved one,
then you can direct
message me on Instagram,
at Lima from Aura.
And I'll send you a link to
the template and outline.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
- Lastly, I just want to
address one more thing
that I read in the comments
and that was the GoFundMe campaign.
So I just want to really clearly state
that the funds raised
from the GoFundMe campaign
are going directly to a company
who's our fiscal sponsor
for JIBBS, the nonprofit,
and it's giving.org.
Giving collects all of the money,
so Mark and I never actually
have access to the funds,
and Giving we'll pay the
hospitals and clinics
directly on Amanda's behalf.
So for every 250,000 raised,
we're going to bring in another
person from the interviews.
And if everyone donates
$10 to the campaign,
everyone that's watching,
we can help everyone on the channel
and even some of the viewers.
So our goal is to make the fund big enough
so that we can cover the
expenses for anyone that applies
and start an application process for it.
But at this time,
we're going to use the
petitions to really drive
insurance companies and the government
to change the industry.
- [Interviewer] Very exciting.
- Cool.
- [Interviewer] Will I be able to do,
like updates with Amanda?
- Absolutely. So we're going
to be doing updates with Amanda
and I-
- [Interviewer] Not that I
haven't done enough already.
- We're going, we're going
to be doing really positive
updates with Amanda.
We're going to be documenting
step-by-step exactly how,
you know, she's, she's benefiting
and exactly the path that
we're taking with her treatment
so that other people can,
can take that model and
apply it to their situations.
And I just met,
my husband and I just had
dinner with Amanda's father
on Friday.
And so Amanda's father was a veteran,
and Amanda is one of four children.
So her three siblings are
actually doing very well.
And when Amanda was younger,
she aspired to be a newscaster.
And so when she was in college,
she was actually chasing that dream.
And so I actually found
it very interesting that
in college, suddenly she's she
began to get very paranoid,
and she had reached out
to her dad and told him,
somebody is watching me.
I think they're surveilling me.
And Larry didn't know how
to spot anything, you know,
any mental illness or anything weird,
so he was concerned for his daughter.
So he changed her phone.
He changed her number.
He was trying to help her
get, you know, be safe.
He didn't know what was going on.
And so, you know,
there were some early onsets
of something more going on.
That's why, what you're doing, Mark,
is really important by
really having people,
having that awareness factor
put out into the public
so that other people watching this video
might be able to detect things early on.
And then, you know, of course
Amanda, like a lot of people,
started hanging out with the wrong crowd.
She started off with abusing marijuana.
And I know a lot of people say
marijuana is very harmless,
but if you have a dissociative disorder
or if possible schizophrenia,
it can actually make
those things a lot worse.
So no drug is safe in my opinion.
It's not just safe to just experiment.
Everybody should be really
careful with their brains.
But yeah, so she, she started to hang out
with the wrong crowd, and
she started to use marijuana.
She began to get more paranoid
and then it just escalated
from other drugs from there.
And that's how we ended
up with a crack addiction
and being homeless.
Her father has tried to get
her housing multiple times,
and every time she's been evicted,
and it hasn't worked out.
And like I said, it's not a housing issue.
When you have such a
severe mental illness,
it's really about getting
treatment and getting proper care.
- [Interviewer] Lima, I
thank you for everything
you're doing for, for
Amanda and maybe others.
And we'll see how it goes.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] There'll
be, will I be able to do,
like updates with Amanda?
- Absolutely. So we're going to be
doing updates with Amanda, and I-
- [Interviewer] Not that I
haven't done enough already.
- We're going, we're going
to be doing really positive
updates with Amanda.
We're going to be documenting
step-by-step exactly how,
you know, she's, she's benefiting
and exactly the path that
we're taking with her treatment
so that other people can,
can take that model and
apply it to their situations.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
- [Lima] Cool.
- [Interviewer] Well, thank you
so much for everything, and.
- [Lima] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] These
will be exciting updates.
- [Lima] Absolutely. I'm very excited
And thank you guys all,
everybody that's watching,
for all of your support and
all the positive feedback.
I really appreciate.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- Yay.